- Everyone out
of the street now.
Go that way.
This way, out of the street.
All you all looking at me
need to get out of the street.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
("Raincoats" by Derek Pope)
- [Gary] It's
gonna be interesting.
He's really
getting into basketball,
you know that?
Mhmmm.
Mom, you had to see
what happened yesterday.
You know it was tough for me
because I wasn't in control.
You know because I couldn't
talk the whole time 'cause the
founders had to talk, you know?
No, I'm not gonna
watch the Super Bowl.
I'm flying home and I'm gonna go
home and hang out with the kids.
Love you, Mom.
Mhmmm, bye.
How are you?
Really good.
The last scene of this
show went really well for me.
Like really well.
And I'm not
fucking kidding with you.
That's literally what it was.
So that was in my mind.
And the way the day
went was in my mind.
And making the green
room, not the green room,
the control room like one of the
young kids who's a fan came
to me he's like, "It's so crazy.
"Control room's like
dead quiet the whole day.
"Every time you're on
there's a buzz and then
"four times everybody's
laughing their ass off." Right?
So all this is happening so
(censored) this nice chat and
I'm like (censored).
You know, he's like talking
about what's gonna happen next
with (censored) this, that.
I'm like, (censored) I mean the
real punchline here is that this
town is now gonna know that
I'm a real star and I'm gonna,
I'm gonna go make
some real magic happen.
(laughs) I know you guys have
known each other a long time so
I thought you'd like that.
It was something in that
moment that made me text you.
The reason I'm really
calling you is I'm telling you,
man, I think we're gonna
have enormous (censored).
Like I genuinely believe,
I believe the bullshit that
I've been pumping you
guys for a decade,
I feel like it's all
cresendoed to the moment.
I really think I've got it.
I just think it's really smart
for me to put the most valuable
asset I have in my life which
is my time in your hands for
five meetings between today
and (censored) 'cause I think
the multiplier will
be exponential.
Maybe it's the
executive (censored),
maybe it's (censored), maybe
it's (censored) that's set up
like (censored) this
guy's gonna run the world
like I'm telling you.
Maybe it's (censored), maybe
it's the CEO of (censored).
I don't know and the cool
part is I'm not looking to
(censored), I'm
looking to be strategic.
I just know I'll blow them away
over a drink and an hour and
good shit will happen for us.
- [DRock] (inaudible)
what are you trying to do?
- What do you mean
what am I trying to do?
I'm trying to do
what I always do,
I'm hacking.
People don't get it.
This shit doesn't
happen by accident.
Happens 'cause of that.
I'm fucking strategic as fuck.
People just think
I'm like, go do it
and funny and a nice guy.
Fucking savage,
that's what I am.
(DRock laughs)
My biz dev skills
are fucking the best.
I just don't show it.
There's not moments to show it.
You're gonna have to beep out
98% if you decide to use this.
Are we reminiscing about some of
the greatest talent of all time?
Hello.
- Hi.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Christine] Christine.
- [Gary] Christine, Gary.
- [Christine] Nice to meet you.
- 'Sup brother?
- Good to see you,
my man. Yeah.
("Raincoats" by Derek Pope)
- Hey, sorry about that.
So (censored)
handcuffed, go ahead.
Super fun.
What I was about to say to Chris
is we have a new website coming
up for Vayner that's going to be
very focused on just examples of
our work in video as I continue
to push this Facebook video
commercial thing but I do think
that if these (censored) run on
this five second bumper during
the Super Bowl I'd like that
featured as well
so super exciting.
Just a lot of fun.
I had an incredible, incredible
meeting with (censored) the new
(censored) with
(censored) last week.
Tyler knows that I'm
trying to see him every 30 days,
every 45 days.
And so, I'm just really excited.
I think it's gonna be a great
year and I just appreciate all
your guys' hustle and I can't
wait to see you guys and keep me
updated on what's going on here.
("Mixed Feelings" by Derek Pope)
- [Crowd] Gary, Gary, Gary!
- I need to find
a spot to do this.
Give me a few minutes.
- [Man] GaryVee, we're live man.
- Hey everybody.
- Hey.
- Thank you, thank you.
I just want to say hello.
- [Chuck] Hey,
it's good to see you.
My name's Chuck.
- You can take
them across the street.
- [Brandon] We have a meeting
later this month but I just
wanted to say hi.
- Pleasure.
- [Brandon] I'll see
you in New York.
Brandon.
- Brandon, I'll see you soon.
Take care. Who do
I make it out to?
- [Man 2] Bro.
- Bro?
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- Like B-R-O?
- [Man 2] (inaudible).
- Photos?
- [Crowd] Gary, Gary, Gary!
- ...When it comes
from your perspective,--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- a boxing match, you know?
You can't throw every
single punch you want
so you have to pace yourself.
(buzzing drowns out sound)
- [Gary] Everyone
beats themselves up.
Don't beat yourself up.
- Yep.
- [Gary] (inaudible)
plus you're 25.
It will take you 16
years to catch up to my age.
You got time.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I think you're putting
too much pressure on yourself
and that's the
real biggest problem.
- Okay.
- [Gary] You're pushing (buzzing
drowns out all other sound).
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You can do everything
wrong for the next seven years.
- Yep.
- [Gary] Everything.
Start figuring it out at
32, and be young as fuck.
- Yeah. The risk is big
so I appreciate that, man.
- Everyone out
of the street now.
Go that way.
All you all looking at me
need to get out of the street.
No, no, no, no that way.
(crowd murmuring)
- I'm just a match, you took it.
You took it.
(whistle blows)
(crowd murmuring)
- [Man 3] GaryVee!
GaryVee!
- [Crowd] Gary, Gary, Gary!
- [Policeman] No, no,
no, no, no!
- [Kyle] Hey Gary, Gary.
Kyle Becker.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Kyle] Good.
Can I take a quick picture, man?
- [Gary] Yeah, let's do it fast.
Guys, these lovely men,
we took, we took us away.
(laughs) Thanks for coming out.
("Mixed Feelings" by Derek Pope)